les autos électriques ce n'est plus
nouveau mais des motomarines électrique
saleh dès cet été sur nos là la première
moto marine au monde entièrement
électrique silencieuse zéro émission
conçue par trois jeunes ingénieurs
formés à miguil qui ont également conçu
une motoneige électrique
vous êtes les nouveaux j armand
bombardier
ces véhicules récréatifs sont
l'aboutissement de la filière électrique
est en train de se mettre en place au
québec avec un peu comme modèle la
fameuse grave aéronautique
c'est le rêve de karim zaghib pionnier
de la pile lithium-ion à hydro québec
est maintenant experts conseils
d'investissement québec
c'est en régime au niveau des ressources
naturelles donc on a besoin du cuir du
graphite du silicium de l'aluminium du
fer du cobol d'unique n ya pas des
métaux rares dans une batterie donc tout
ça c'est relié à un sol qui met quoi on
a toute ses ressources
on a tous on a tous dans une cellule de
batterie il y à une anode et une cathode
séparées par un électrolyte qui exige
des matériaux bien précis pour
fonctionner la filière commence par
lamine les matières premières environ 95
% du contenu de la note the great voici
le produit fini le minerai sera bientôt
istres est à grande échelle du gisement
de taille mondiale de matawinie près de
saint michel des saints 25 tonnes de
roche pour une tonne de minerai qui est
raffiné pour l'instant dans cette usine
de démonstration avant l'ouverture d'un
centre de transformation à bécancour
nouveau monde a de l'ambition dans un
marché dominé pour l'instant le 100% par
la chine
je pense de québec est très bien
positionné parce qu'on a des bon
gisement bien développés qui sont
relativement près de la
commercialisation comparer les autres
juridictions sur la planète
ça c'est un gros avantage qu'il faut
préserver des firmes spécialisées pense
qu'on va avoir besoin d'environ deux
points 8 millions de tonnes
supplémentaires de greffe et avant 20 25
et hauts de l'aude 3.5 millions avant
2 2 mais le train voilà pour l'anode
pour la cathode il faut du lithium
extrait de cette matière le spo du maine
qui provient du gisement whabouchi de
nemaska la compagnie en difficulté a été
reprise pour moitié par investissement
québec et deux compagnies une
britannique et une américaine
nemaska devrait reprendre sa production
de lithium
direction une compagnie comme johnson
mathy à candiac qui produit la matière
première de la cathode à base de lithium
fer phosphate et carbone le raffinage du
lfp de qualité batterie est un procédé
complexe hautement technologique
nous sommes un acteur clé dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement positionner en trois
lignes 1a les stocks de matières
premières est les fabricants de cellules
de bharti finale et on regardait la
chaîne d'approvisionnement c'est ok
c'est bien beau tout ça mais la batterie
en fin de vie qu'est ce qui advient avec
cette batterie des matières premières
récupérables les matériaux de batteries
en fin de vie lithium graphique
électrolytes et autres métaux seront
recyclés à 95%
le projet est en place chez recyclage
étions à montréal alors pour nous ce
qu'on fait en exploite la mine urbaine
c'est que la batterie c'est pas un
déchet qu'on doit traiter
c'est une ressource qu'on doit exploiter
l'avenir vers se trouve aussi dans
l'économie circulaire avec une
technologie sophistiquée avec un procédé
dit dont métallurgie comme celui de
lycée en développe on peut les utiliser
à l'infini
[Musique]
tiens
mais le chaînon manquant c'est les
cellules de batteries elles sont
fabriquées en asie d'une batterie s'il
sait que la cellule on parle de cellules
lorsqu on fabrique la batterie d'une
voiture donc on a à peu près 4000
cellule
le pack et à une pression que ce pack là
il valait vers 100 dollars le kilo watt
heure on n'a pas de cellule et encore on
n'a pas dit s'il y est encore au québec
puis sam chicotte parce que parce que on
a eu tout on est on est on ne les
connaissances pour le faire hydro québec
j'ai vu des lignes de montage pilotes
sont capables de faire vraiment la
technologie lfp lithium fer phosphate
c'est vraiment une acquis au québec au
niveau expertise elle devrait se
produire ici au québec pourquoi parce
qu'on à l'énergie verte et on est
capable à produire à un prix raisonnable
comparables ou inférieurs à celui de
l'asie
c'est important parce que la batterie
moi je la vois comme une sécurité
nationale elle est importante
le reste de la filiale est pas mal en
place lyon pionnier des autobus et des
camions de saint-jérôme va ouvrir une
usine d'assemblage de batteries et
continuent d'accumuler de gros contrats
en amérique du nord
les autos elles ne seront pas faites ici
aujourd'hui une spécificité
au québec on est bon à faire des camions
en les bons à faire des autobus
on y va en faire des motos on est bons
faire dire des motoneiges etc
on a nos voisins en ontario que ils
veulent fabriquer des voitures il ya
bien le projet arrow ce projet d'auto
canadienne est dirigée par l'association
des producteurs de pièces automobiles du
canada avec de grands joueurs
[Musique]
tout va très vite
bien malin celui qui aurait prédit que
le nouveau homme se réveille le
fabricant jihem vient de le ressusciter
il devient électrique et même approche
chez ford qui fabrique le symbole de
tous les excès le f-150 lui aussi passe
au mode électrique en option
à moyen terme le progrès se dirige vers
la promesse des batteries dit solide
plus puissantes moins lourdes et à
charge rapide
la seule à être commercialisée est
fabriqué à boucherville par la filiale
du français bolloré
la batterie lithium-ion et la batterie
tout solide elle va occuper pas mal
la voiture électrique mais en revanche
l'hydrogène il va occuper tout qu'on
appelle ça le transport l'eau les
camions et aussi les trains et plus tard
à long terme c'est les actes
déjà la france vient de commander des
trains de banlieue à hydrogène et airbus
a300 possible daviau à hydrogène dont
les premiers voleront vers 2035 un
hydrogène vert c'est-à-dire
renouvelables avec l'hydroélectricité du
québec est déjà produit par la française
air liquide avec l'américaine comence
par hydrolyse à bécancour
mais la prochaine révolution aura lieu
cet hiver dans nos campagnes et nos
forêts avec les premières motoneige
électrique de taïga d'ailleurs on
pourrait départ est juste le moteur le
silence l'expérience c'est ça qui sont
pas là enfin le silence la peine hilaire
pure est ce que on a un plan québec
je pense qu'il ya un excellent plan au
québec moi je trouve si jamais vu les
étoiles s'aligner taille à plusieurs
années d'avant sur ses concurrents qui
se lance aussi dans l'électrique comme
lyon et nouveau monde graphique
la compagnie sera bientôt cotée en
bourse
[Musique]